abone ol
[Müzik]
mi
Evet herkese merhaba
bugün
sizlere biraz
ağzınızın tadını keşfetmeniz için ki
herkesin ağzını tadı olduğu kesin ama
ağzınızın tadını keşfetmek için
biraz ipuçları vereceğim
Bu arada Bulgari borna bağlayacağız
gerçekten yeniden doğmak ve lezzet
Aslında iç içe geçmiş İki kavram biz bu
gün günde üç öğün yemek yiyoruz ama asla
baktığınız zaman her öğünde kendimizi
yeniden yaratıyoruz yeniden doğuyoruz
Eğer bu oyunlardan birini ikisini
atlasak hiçbir şey olmaz 3-5 gün bir şey
yemesek hiçbir şey olmaz Ama bunu çok
uzun tutamayız Fransızca'da lokantaya
Restoran derler değil mi Restoran diye
bir laf var restaurant lafı nereden
gelir ve en sondan yeniden yapılanmak
Onun için bizim için yeme içme işi çok
çok önemli bizi yeniden her gün
duymamızı sağlayan yeniden yaşamamızı
sağlayan unsur yeme içme Peki şimdi
lezzet algısı
kişiseldir ve kültürel dir ben çıkıp
size falanca yemek böyle tadıyor filanca
içecek şöyle tadıyor dediğimde sadece
kendi algım doğrultusunda size bir
şeyler anlatırız bu öyle sizin için öyle
tadıyor demek değildir Mesela
burada yüz kişiyi alalım
herkese vanilya çubuğu katalım büyük
ihtimalle 17 kişi hiçbir şey kokmayacak
hiçbir şey tanımayacak Çünkü ortalama da
Dünya nüfusunun yüzde 17'si vanilya
aromasına kördü uyu
Allah hepimizin tek alacağı orta
kalacağı olma var o da kahve kahve
toplumun yüzde yüzü tarafından takılıp
toplanabiliyor Evet onun için bir
kişiseldir Doğuştan dna'mızda gelen bir
özelliktir taktığımız He kokladığımız
kokuları ve tatları algılayabilmek
bazılarına aşırı hassas sızdır
bazılarında çözmüştür önce benim gibi
gurma o karaların bir şeyi nasıl tattığı
nasıl koktuğunu size söylediklerinde
dinlemeyin siz nasıl tanıyorsanız nasıl
korkuyorsanız öyledir ikincisi kültürel
dir yaşadığımız coğrafya aileniz gibi
birçok unsur sizin hayatta lezzet
aldığınızı etkiler değiştirir Mesela bir
Güneydoğu Anadolu'da yaşayan insanın acı
algısıyla
daha batıda yaşayan bir insanın Ege'de
yaşayan bir insanın acı algısı
birbirinden çok farklıdır evet hadi ile
Çünkü kültür olarak değil o coğrafyada
Güneydoğu Anadolu coğrafyasında çok da
acılı yemekleri ön için başla diyelim ki
lezzet algısı kişisel ve kültürel dir
bir şimdi çok basit vites yapacağım size
Lütfen cevapları kendi kafanızla düşünün
şimdi
Bazı insanlar
solda tepede gördüğünüz gibi bitter
çikolata sever bazıları sütlü çikolata
sıdır kim insan brokoli karnabahar
Efendim
brüksel lahanası gibi sebze tatlarını
çok sever kimi insanda Bütün ömrüm
boyunca hiç sebzeyi miyim Sadece et
yiyebilirler
da aynı İnsanlar bir elbise aldıklarında
etiketi hemen batmaya başlar acil gidip
etiket keserler ver Çünkü etiket çok
rahatsız eder bu gruptaki insanlar ise
hiç umurlarında olmaz etiketi var mıydı
farkında bile vermezler bir grup insan
dedi bu taraftaki insanlar
yemeğin Tadına bakmadan tuz koyarlar var
diğer taraftaki insanlar ise genelde
yemeği tadına bakıp gerekiyorsa tuz
eklediler
hepimizin ağız yapıları birbirinden
farklı Ama genel olarak yaptığımız
çalışmaları sonunda şunu bulduk toplumu
üç gruba ayırıyoruz
mesela yemeğin tadına Hiç Bakmadan tuz
koyanlar
Barca kahveyi çayı ya sütlü ya şekerli
ve az demli içenler bunlara Hyper testir
hassas ağızlar diyoruz de bu olduğumuz
hepimiz doğduğumuz hepimizin ağzı çok
hassas oluyor Yine olmasa soluyor
bebekleri düşünün gitti de zaman içinde
ağzımız daha sertleşiyor daha toleransı
yüksek ağızlara dönüşüyoruz Ama
bazılarınız aramızda hassas ağzı olarak
kalıyorlar şu O gün insanlar genelde
dediğim gibi kahveye mutlaka içecekler s
şeker veya süt koyarak onu geçirirler
sebzelerden pek hoşlanmazlar etkinliği
tercih ederler yemeğin Tadına bakmadan
tuz koyarlar ve birçok lezzet onlara
sanki amplifikatör den çıkmış gibi çok
fazla gelir baharattan pek hoşlanmaz bu
iyi veya kötü bir şey değil Bir yaklaşık
toplumun yüzde 25'i hassas ağız doğruyu
toleranslı ağızlarda diğer yüzde yirmi
beş toplumun bir diğer yüzde 25'i Bunlar
siyah kahve sade Türk kahvesi
espresso en sert baharatlı yemekler bu
bu düşünüyorlar Bir de ortada 150 var
bunlara testtir diyoruz bunlarda aslında
bütün gıda sanayinin yemekleri
içecekleri tasarladıkları büyük Grup
Bunlar ikisine de yakın olabilirler ama
daha çok ortada var dediğim gibi hassas
ağız olarak doğuyoruz gitgide Ağzımızın
toleransı yükseliyor Herkes kendine bir
yer bulabildi mi burada bu gruplardan
birinde mis ama Sizce kaçınız ben
kesinlikle hassas ağzım der aranızda
Bu biraz da yüz kişi var burada herhalde
25'ini kaldırmış olması lazım Evet peki
Ben kesinlikle kendimi toleranslı az
hissediyorum diyen var mı
görüyorsunuz herkes vardı onun için aynı
yiyecek farklı gruplara farklı biçimde
tanıyor peki
o lezzetlidir Aslında lezzet dediğiniz
şey Biz bunu gastronomi falan
biliyorsunuz çok moda Hemen Kafayı
kazıtıp dövmeleri yaptır Şef oluyorsun
çok bu aralar moda bu Gastronomi nedir
ve lezzetlidir tabi lezzetin peşinden
koşmak Aslında lezzet Burada gördüğünüz
gibi Kapı güvenlik lezzet bizim
yiyeceğimizi yemeyeceğim izi ayırmamızı
sağlayan unsur bizim lezzet diyoruz
bundan haz alıyoruz ama aslında
arkasında bir fonksiyon var bizi
zehirleyecek hasta edecek yiyecekleri ve
içecekleri tüketmemeniz sağlayan bir
kapı güvenlik sistemimiz acı lezzet
konusunda da romantik davran sakta asla
tamamen arkasında Mekanik bir neden var
mesela bitkilerde de meyvelerde de
lezzet yeni bir koruyucu önlem niye
meyveler hamken acıdır sevimsiz dir
Çünkü çekirdeği ya daha olgunlaşmamış
tır hayvanlar ve insanlar onu yiyip
çekil 12 yaratmasın Çünkü daha çoğalacak
halde değildir çekirdek daha hamdı Rojin
Tadı da acıdır bitkilerdir ne zaman
çekirdek olgunlaşır artık o çekirdek
taşınmak isteniyor ki başka bir yerde
Group Co ölçü olabilirsin O zaman o
meyve tatlılaşır lezzetlenir ki
insanlara ve hayvanlara cazip gelsin
unuttuk etsinler
Bir de ağzımız tatları adapte olur
unutmayın mesela çok hoş gelmeyebilir
Ama hiçbiriniz şu diyebilir misiniz Ben
kendi tükürüğünü tadını biliyorum
Ağzımızın içinde 24 saat durduğu için o
tat biz onu sanki tadı yokmuş gibi
hissederiz Halbuki Her çeşit kişinin
tükürüğünü bir tadı var belli bir tada
belli bir süre maruz kalırsınız o tadı
daha az almaya başlarsınız Onun için
yemeklerin yanına şefler orduevler
koyuyorlar başka tatlar koyuyorlar Bu
yemeği yerken devamlı aynı yemeği
yerseniz bir yerden sonra o ilk verdiği
heyecan mu başlarda da azalmaya başlar
Aslında azalıyor Siz adapte oluyorsunuz
onun yanına orduevler başka lezzetler
koyuyoruz ki
ondan tadınca bunu yeniden döndüğümüz
daha gerçekten çok güzelmiş devam et
Peki şimdi zaman içinde Ağzımızın yapısı
değişir dedik özellikli 40-50 yaştan
sonra kadınlarda erkeklerde farklı komik
üzere daha az tat almaya başlarız
Çünkü Ağzımızın içindeki tat
reseptörleri sayısı azalır sıcaktan
baharattan sıcak içecekten yiyecekten
baharattan vesaire azalır Fakat burada
şöyle bir durum var hani erkeklerin ise
Ah annemin yaptığı karnıyarık eşim
yapamıyor aynısını
Aslında kabahati şimdi değil
ve o günkü anneyi
Işıl Masak bugüne getirsek bütün
malzemeyi de bugün Işıl atak getirsek
benim ağzımın yapısı değişti Son 30
yılda 20 yıl da ben aynı tadı almıyorum
yediğim
az yapımız değişti çocukluğumuzdaki Bir
çok lezzetli özlemle alırız ama aynısını
Bugün bize verseler aynı tatmaz Çünkü
Ağzımızın içi değiştirdi bir istisna var
kadınlar
kadınlar hamilelik ve emzirme
dönemlerinde yeniden hop hassas azalır
niye cam kandil için özellikle bebek
için yedikleri içtikleri çok hassas
olmak zorundalar ki Zararlı rahatsız
edici birşey gelmesinler
bebeğin ihtiyaçlarını farkında olmadan
bilirler bu aş ermek diyoruz
bu anneler hamilelik dönemlerinde
dediğim gibi ve emzirme dönemlerinde
tekrar hassas az olurlar sonra süreci
sonunda normal ağızlarına geri dönerler
Onun için hamile kalınır mide sık sık
bulanır rahatsız edici bir çok tadı gel
istemezler ya aşırı isterler İşte bu
gene bu bu vücudun bodyguardı Games
üç yaşına kadar çok hassas ağzı oluruz
dedim
sadece tatlı bir yağlı istedim Çünkü
benim için arkasına bir şeyler ki bebeğe
Aman Tatlı ye yağlı ye hiçbir bebeğim
brokoli yediği gördünüz mü
bu ispanak nefret eder çünkü bitter
patlardı Bunlar Ama yağlı ve tatlı
bebeğin Es kaza aç kalırsa hayatta
kalması için gerekli enerjiler Uçun
bebekler pofuduk olurlar böyle tombi
sonuç bacaklarla Niye stoklar
Çünkü beslenmeyi kontrol edemedikleri
için üç yaşından sonra İşler değişir
artık bitter tatlara maruz kalarak
bitler yeme belli demektir bitter toksik
tat bitter dediğimiz Acı yeme beni
demektir ama kontrollü miktarda anneye
babaya eşe dosta bakarak yeni öğreniriz
yavaş yavaş bitter tatlara
tahammül Edebilir hale geliriz ne of
17'ye bir şey var bazılarınız ömrümüz
boyunca neofobi kalırız yenilik korkusu
yeni yiyeceği İnsan doğduğunda korkaktır
Yenice yemez korkar Baran annesi babası
arkadaşlar yiyorsa
yaramaya yeni Ne istediğimi birçok çocuk
farklı bir şeyler yemek istemez balık
Yemen benden niye biliyor Çünkü bu
yenilik korkusunda 3 yaş sonrasında
yavaş yavaş atmaya başlarız ama bazı
çocuklarda bu daha uzun sürer ama
çocuklara zorla bir şey getirmeyin
bilmediği azot sadece temkinli olduğu
için bu beni zehirlenme diye sorduğu
için eğer vereceksiniz yeni bir yiyecek
evde bildiği bir yiyeceğin yanına azıcık
koyarak alışarak tür
Evet Kavruk lezzetli bizim için çok
önemlidir
mangal değil mi kahve çikolata
asla gene lezzet falan değil bir yiyecek
ısıya maruz kaldı mı üzerindeki mikro
organizmalar ölür yani o Eğer küflendi
ise bozulduysa üzerindeki mikro
organizmaları öldürüp yiyeceğimiz zaman
bize hasta etmeyeceğini bildiğiniz için
biz Kavruk lezzetleri sinir ama biz buna
romantik olarak seviyoruz dediğiniz için
seviyoruz Halbuki arkasında beynimizin
arkası bir şey diyor ki Ya hayır bu
güvenmeyecek yiyebilirsin gerçekten
Canımız da o zaman çıkıyor
Şu Evet
Ee
ne dedi Hatıralar Var aslında çok önemli
bir şey birçok yemeği veya içeceği
hatıralarından dolayı ya seviyoruz ya
seviyoruz
mesela çocukluğumuzda kavga edilen bir
ortamda bir şey tatmış hızdır ömrümüz
boyunca o an hatırlamasak da o
yiyecekten veya içecekten nefret
edebiliriz ya da çok hoş bir ortamda
gayet vasat bir yiyecek yapmışızdır işte
gene o yiyeceği bütün ömrümüz boyunca
severek hatırlarız atölyeci
güzelliğinden değil o anı bize
hatırlattığı için farkına varmadı
buradaki etkisi diyoruz Hani ilk Çok
taki değişenler bütün geceyi klozete
sarılarak geçirirler ya onun için
rasyonlarına tekila ikisi diyor Evet
peki
tatmayan kokmayan koklayan insanlar var
mı aramızda var öyle doğan insanlar ya
da belli bir
bu müdahaleler veya kaza ile böyle
birşey geçirenler var bunlarda yiyecek
içeceği dokusuyla pazarlıyor bakın hep
yiyecekte Tadı kokusu diyoruz yalan bir
de dokusu var kırılgan çıtırdayan yağlı
kıvamlı ısı gevşek değil mi Mesela bir
salemi bakın Salih'in dokusuna bakın
birde sütün dokusuna bakın Saadet daha
kıvamlı bir içecektir o kıvam larda bize
o dokularda bize yiyecekler içecekte
hakverir unutmayın mesela kokusu olmazsa
soğanla elmayı ayıramayız biliyor
musunuz kokuya Masak
Gözümüz kapalı Soğanlı elmayı karıştırır
Bu sadece dokuları çok çok benziyor ama
bu tadını çok iyi alıyoruz biz çok iyi
tamam toplayan insanlar değiliz biliyor
musunuz
şöyle bir örnek vereyim ses değiştikçe
lezzet aldığımız değişir çok değişir
O çok gürültülü bir yerde en güzel
yemeği yiyin tadını alamazsın
abone ol
Evet
şimdi bir çalışma yaptık şunu gördük
yürüteceğiz Ben gurmeyim çok iyi tanırım
koklarım aslında
Ali Bey'in hareketli dediğimiz yiyeceği
veya içeceği gördüğümüz zaman yüzde
doksana çıkıyor
wart adı koklarken yüzde 5'te
Bu bir gözümüzle yiyoruz bir laf var
yani gözün doysun
Ama
gerçekten yiyeceğin içeceğin görüntüsü
en önemli Siz dünyanın en güzel yemeğini
böyle çamur gibi bir püre haline getirin
önünüze koyun işte açmaz
Mesela bir çay düşünün çamur gibi kim
içmek ister değil mi
Ya aslında biz lezzeti bugün baktığımız
zaman tat koku desek de aslında lezzet
temel di di tat tarafında Tatlı ekşi
tuzlu bitter ve umami a sulandıran dan
oluşur bunun üzerine sıvı dediğimiz
kokular eklenir onun üzerine doku
yiyeceğin içeceğin ısısı rengi biçimi
çıkarttığı ses eklenir Ondan sonra da
onu yediğiniz ortam kimlerle yediğimiz
gibi çevre faktörleri eklenir Mesela bir
şey yerken içerken keyif vermedi mi size
kabahati yiyecekte bulmayın karşınızdaki
değiştirir Yanlış insanla yiyorsunuz
ya hani zehir zıkkım oldu derler ya
hiçbir şeyimize girdik Evet ortam kötü
semirsek çok kötü ışıkta da çok yüksek
seste sevimsiz bir konuyu konuşurken
yediğiniz içtiğiniz yaşanmaz
ama biz dediğim gibi çevreye de lezzet
konusunda hastalık
O çok kısa bir şeyden de bahsedeceğim
bugün Bakın büyük kahve zincirleri böyle
kapaklarla karton bardakları havalı
markalarla çıkıyorlar içecekler böyle
kola bilmem ne çat çat ne farklı vardır
biliyorsunuz büyük hata yaptıklarını
Çünkü böyle bir konteynırın içinde
içtiğiniz kahvenin rengini
göremiyorsunuz
kokusunu alamıyorsunuz sadece tadıyla
idare ediyorsunuz Onun için şimdi yeni
teknolojik çalışmalar var Burada
gördüğünüz gibi bu bu sıçramayı
engelleyen kapaklarda kokuyu ve rengi
gösteren kapaklara gitmek kutu
içeceklerde kutunun tepesini tamamen
açılması gibi çözümler arıyoruz Çünkü
gerçekten yediğimizi içtiğimizi tatmak
koklamak dışında görmemizle gerekiyor
ısısını hissetmemiz gerekiyor ve
olduğumuz ortamda bu lezzete büyük
katkıda bulunuyor Evet çok büyük bir 300
Dostlar ama zaman 18 dakika olduğu için
burada kesiyorum Umarım keyif
almışsınızdır ya da en azından kafanızda
bu işi farklı biçimde düşünmek için soru
işaretleri yarattı bilmişimdir Hepinize
bol keyifli afiyetli günler diyor ya